الجزيره نجوى سمري نجوان اول ما هي
المعلومات التي اوردتها اسرائيل بشان
تفجير العبوه على حدود قطاع غزه
بجرافه عسكريه
نعم الناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي اكد قبل
قليل بان بانه قام باطلاق قذائف من
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه عند الحدود مع غزه
باتجاه موقع وصفه بانه موقع عسكري تابع
لحركه حماس وذلك ردا على تفجير عبوه ناسفه
عن بعد كانت بالقرب من قوه عسكريه هندسيه
تابعه لقوات الاحتلال كانت تعمل داخل
الاراضي الفلسطينيه من الحدود ضمن ما يعرف
بعمليات مسح للمنطقه الحدوديه تقوم بها
بين الحين والاخر قوات من فرق الهندسه
التابعه للجيش الاسرائيلي لكشف المناطق
الحدوديه
الجيش الاسرائيلي بدا يجري عمليات تحقيق
واسعه في هذا
الحادث لفحص ما اذا كانت هذه العبوه قد
زرعت هذا اليوم ام انها كانت موجوده في
السابق واستهدفت احدى الجرافات التي او
الاليات العسكريه التي كانت تعمل في
الموقع لقوات جيش الجيش الاسرائيلي في
الموقع نحن في البدايه كان هناك اعتقاد
لدى الجانب الاسرائيلي بانه تم
الرد على اطلاق القذيفه من غزه فجر هذا
اليوم باتجاه المستوطنات الاسرائيليه على
الجانب الاخر من الحدود لكن عند هذا عند
فجر هذا اليوم دوت صافرات انذار ولكن
بعدها بقليل اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي بان
قذيفه
صاروخيه تم رصدها اطلقت من قطاع غزه لكنها
سقطت في الاراضي الفلسطينيه داخل قطاع غزه
هذا ما تم الاعلان عنه فجر هذا اليوم ولكن
بعدها بساعات اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه
في اعقاب عمليات واسعه ومسح للمناطق
الحدوديه عثر على
هذه القذيفه داخل الحدود على الجانب
الاسرائيلي
وعندها تم التاكيد بان صافرات الانذار
التي دورت كانت بفعل هذه القذيفه التي
سقطت في الجانب الاسرائيلي بالقرب من
مستوطنات لكنه لم يبلغ عن وقوع ايه اصابات
كذلك باستهداف هذه العبوه الناسفه للاليات
العسكريه لم يكن هناك اي اصابات كذلك بحسب
البيان العسكري
الاسرائيلي لكن هذا يحدث بعد ساعات ايضا
على حاله من التاهب التي اعلنتها
السلطات الاسرائيليه الاجهزه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه في اعقاب عمليه جنين يوم امس
سواء كان في الحدود مع قطاع غزه وايضا في
منطقه القدس حيث تم تعزيز منظومه القبه
الحديديه عند الحدود وهو ما يحدث عاده بعد
كل عمليه عسكريه ينفذها جيش الاحتلال
الضفه الغربيه
وقد راينا انه يعني قام بقتل العديد من
الشبان الفلسطينيين في هذه العمليه وفي
العاده يعلن مباشره عن حاله من التاهب
خشيه ان يتم الرد على مثل هذه العمليات من
قطاع غزه المره الاخيره التي تم استهداف
فيها المستوطنات الاسرائيليه في منطقه
غلاف غزه كانت بعد عمليه نابلس ايضا التي
استشهد فيها احد عشر فلسطينيا وهي في
العاده تكون او او ترجح الاجهزه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه بانها مواجهه محدوده تقوم
فيها المقاومه الفلسطينيه باطلاق الصواريخ
في رساله بانها تقف الى جانب الضفه
الغربيه بينما يقوم الجيش الاسرائيلي بقصف
مواقع يقول انها تابعه لحركه المقاومه
حماس طيب النجوان لو لو اخذنا شيئا من
التفصيل بما بما ذكرتيه قبل قليل بان
اسرائيل تتفحص ان كانت هذه العبوه قديمه
ام انها زرعت
بشكل يعني قريب بمعنى هل المقصود ان
اسرائيل تريد ان تعرف ان كان هناك علاقه
لهذه العبوه بما حصل في جنين بالامس ام
انه حادث عربي يمكن ان يحصل في اي وقت
هو بالتاكيد ليس حادث عرضي حسن ولكن
التحقيق والفحص يتم حول موعد زرع هذه
العبوه غالبيه الترجيحات تشير بانه تم
وضعها بعد فجر هذا اليوم او بعد عمليه
جنين اي في الساعات الاخيره لكن من جهه
اخرى يقوم الجيش الاسرائيلي بالتحقق من
موعد زرع هذه العبوه لفحص فيما اذا كانت
قد وضعت في السابق بالقرب او قبل عمليه
جنين بالقرب من الحدود لانه بالعاده هناك
تقوم قوات الاحتلال بشكل دائم بالعمل عند
الحدود ضمن عمليات تقول بانها عفوا لكشف
الحدود والمناطق
الحدوديه المتاخمه للمستوطنات في منطقه
غلاف غزه ربما يكون هناك تبعات فيما اذا
اتضح ان هذه العبوه تم زرعها في الساعات
الاخيره بعد عمليه جنين بمعنى رغم ان هذا
الرد المح موجوده باطلاق النيران المدفعيه
الذي قام بها الجيش الاسرائيلي قبل قليل
كرد على زرع هذه العبوه ولكن ربما اذا
اتضح بان لذلك علاقه في عمليه جنين قد
يكون الوضع مرشح الى المزيد من المواجهه
ولكن حتى الان يبدو ان الامر هو مواجهه
محدوده رد ورد فعل على هذه العمليه نحن
نتحدث دائما عن رسائل من قطاع غزه ترسل
للجانب الفلسطيني في الضفه بان غزه تقف
الى جانب المقاومه في الضفه الغربيه وهذا
يحدث عاده بعد كل عمليه لجيش الاحتلال في
الضفه الغربيه لاسيما هذه العمليات
الواسعه التي ينفذها جيش الاحتلال في مدن
الضفه الغربيه تحديدا في منطقتي جنين
ونابلس في الاونه الاخيره كنت قد قلت ان
المره الاخيره التي تم فيها اطلاق صواريخ
من قبل فصائل المق اومه الفلسطينيه باتجاه
مستوطنات غلاف غزه كانت في الشهر الماضي
مباشره بعد عمليه نابلس التي استشهد
خلالها ايضا 11 فلسطينيه حسن شكرا